Transcriber: gaith Takrity
المدقّق: Nawal Sharabati
قصتي في قلمي.
جئتُ اليوم لأشارككم في تجربتي الشخصية،
التي من خلالها وصلت إلى العالمية.
طبعًا، ولدت ولادة طبيعية مثل أي طفل.
في عمر ثماني سنوات، دخلت بقصة جديدة.
لاحظ والدايّ أن هناك
نموًا غير طبيعي في جسمي،
وهنا بدأ القلق.
بدآ يبحثان عن تشخيص من طبيب إلى طبيب،
من مستشفى إلى مستشفى، من عيادة إلى عيادة،
والأيام تمر والسنوات تمضي
دون الحصول على حل.
طبعًا، بالأمل الموجود عند كل أب وأم،
في أنهما يساعدا ابنهما
على التقدم في الحياة،
وصلنا لتصنيف وضعي الصحي
“روماتيزم بالمفاصل“،
نمو غير طبيعي في كل مفاصل الجسم.
أنهينا المرحلة الابتدائية، بألم.
سرنا في المرحلة الإعدادية بصعوبة أكثر،
ووجد أبي ووجدت أمي،
الحل بالأمل الذي أعطياني إياه،
لأنه لا يوجد حل في التدخل الطبي.
وهنا بالأمل الموجود الذي أعطياني إياه،
بدأت التكيف مع الواقع،
أصبحت حركتي قليلة،
وتباطأت إنجازاتي،
وخاصة في المرحلة الثانوية.
أصبحت في الصف الثاني عشر،
في هذه المرحلة، اضطررت  أن أدخل
الى المشفى حتى أجري؛
عمليات جراحية من أكبرها
وهي زراعة أربع مفاصل بلاتين في قدميّ.
بقيت خمس سنوات في المشفى،
ما بين جراحة وما بين علاج وما بين تأهيل.
وهنا فكرت مع نفسي،
كان عندي تحدّيان، ورسالتي مهمة
لكل أب وابن ولكل أخ وأخت،
أنكم أنتم مَن تبثون الحياة،
إذا كان عندكم حالة تعاني من إعاقة حركية.
طبعًا أجريت العمليات،
وأنا في المشفى فكرت مع نفسي،
عندي تحديّان كبيران:
الأول، لا أستطيع أن أكمل
الدراسة الأكاديمية.
والتحدي الثاني، ما في علاج للصحة.
وهنا رجعت أفكر بنفسي، رجعتُ إلى نفسي،
بعدما اعتقدتُ أن العلاج من الخارج،
اكتشفت أن العلاج في داخلي.
غيرت طريقة تفكيري في أن أستثمر
نقاط القوة التي عندي،
حيث ليس هناك وقت لأبني نقاط قوة.
مرّت خمس سنوات عليّ في المشفى
كانت أصعب لحظات حياتي.
خمس سنوات،
جراحات،
و400 خيطٍ جراحي مكان مفاصل البلاتين.
من طفل شبه عاجز حركيًا،
على الكرسي،
الوضع صعب.
قمتُ باستغلال نقطتين إيجابيتين:
النقطة الأولى، حب التعليم،
والنقطة الثانية، اهتمامي في عالم الأطفال.
هنا بدأت قصة ثالثة،
مرحلة جديدة أسطرها في حياتي،
وهي أن أسير في مسار -
التثقيف الذاتي وهو أن أعلّم نفسي بنفسي.
وهنا بدأت أستخدم القراءة،
وهنا بدأت أتلّقى دورات
عن بعد كوني أعيش في المشفى،
بيتي الثاني حيث قضيت فيه خمس سنوات.
انتهيتُ من مرحلة العلاج،
وبالأمل الموجود عند والديّ،
تشكّل عندي مناعة معنوية
أستطيع أن أتكيف فيها مع الواقع.
طرحتُ مبادرة في الحد
من التلعثم عند الأطفال.
من اهتمامي في عالم الأطفال،
وحبي في التعامل معهم،
وجدت عندهم مشكلة مناسبة جدًا
للعنوان الذي أعمل عليه.
بدأت المسيرة وخرجتُ من  المشفى.
بدأنا في طرح المبادرة.
وتحولت المبادرة إلى مشروع ذي رؤية ورسالة.
وعندها نسيت وضعي الصحي
حيث استخدمت العلم للخروج من المعاناة.
من هذه المنطقة إلى هذه
المنطقة بمنهجية علمية،
ومستشارين يدعمونني،
وطبعًا مع الدعم الأسري.
حولنا المشروع من تعليم
اللغة العربية إلى مؤسسة.
بدأت أسافر من دولة  إلى دولة،
وبدأت فكرتي تنتشر،
تنقلت في أحياء القدس من حي إلى حي،
حمّلت نفسي مسؤولية مجتمعية،
وبالأمل الذي أعطياني إياه أبي وأمي
لأنشره إلى الآخرين حتى إلى الأولاد
الذين يعانون من التلعثم
والتأتأة كنتُ أشكل لهم
مناعة معنوية لتكتمل المسيرة.
كان يركز مشروعنا على كثير من الأمور،
استخدمنا ثلاث أدوات للحد
من التلعثم عند الأطفال،
وهي بسيطة جدًا.
الخطوة الأولى،
عندما يحضر الطفل إلينا،
مهم جدًا أن نجري معه مقابلة.
الحالة النفسية للطفل، والمزاج العام
هما المشكّلان الأكبر
لإضعاف قدراته اللغوية.
و هنا أريد أن أعطيكم معلومة مهمة جدًا
كثير من الناس لا يعرفونها.
إن مشكلة التلعثم،
هو اضطراب يصيب الذكور أكثر من الإناث،
أي أن الأنثى قدراتها اللغوية
أعلى بكثير من الذكر،
وهذه إحصائية علمية.
والمعلومة الثانية أنه أكثر من 90%
من ضعف اللغة بجميع مستوياتها
عند الأطفال هي نفسي وليس لغوي،
بمعنى، إذا كان بناء الطفل
مع لغته غير سليم، تصبح لغته غير سليمة.
قد يكون أسلوب التعليم غير مناسب
من الأم إلى الطفل،
تعرض الطفل إلى موقف هاب أو خاف منه،
فشكّل عنده عشوائية لغوية
غير منضبطة في قدراته ومهاراته.
فمهم جدًا أن نفرق ما بين السبب والنتيجة،
عند ابني لعثمة، هذه نتيجة وليست سبب.
عند ابني تأتأة وابني ضعيف
في القراءة والكتابة.
كل هذه التقييمات أو التصنيفات
أو التشخيص هي نتيجة وليست سبب.
السبب في البيت.
هل تدلّلون أولادكم كثيرًا؟
بدلًا من أن تقول له: “هل تريد
أن تشرب ماءً، تقول (بدك مبو؟).”
من هنا يبدأ الأمر.
ليس هناك وعيًا صوتيًا.
بدّك ننّا، هذه أول مشكلة في التلعثم،
(بدك تروح عند تاتا)
اسمها ستك، وليس تاتا،
أتريد أن تلعب؟ أتريد أن تشرب؟
قولوا له الكلمات الكاملة ذات المعنى.
يتوجه إلينا الطفل  ونقوم بتقييمه،
وندرس حالته المزاجية.
لدى أغلبية الأطفال عقد نفسية
غير طبيعية في اللغة العربية،
هي عقد نفسية كما ترون،
وليست مشكلة مهارات.
أنك ضعيف في المهارة،
هذه ليست مشكلة، هذه نتيجة.
أنا أريد السبب، هل تحب اللغة؟
فأسأله سؤالًا، ماذا تحب
أن تتعلم عندما تكبر؟
مقابلة غير تقليدية، ليس امتحان
وماذا تعرف من الحروف والقواعد؟
ماذا تكتب؟ وماذا تقرأ؟ هذه نتائج،
وهذه نصيحة إلى المعلمين والمراكز،
أن نركز على الأسباب وليس النتائج.
بعد ما أسأله ماذا تريد أن تتعلم
عندما تكبر، ويقول لي مثلًا مهندس.
استخدمت هنا الأداة الأولى الفكرية،
يعني نفترض أن اسمة محمد،
وأقول له أنت المهندس محمد،
وتصبح ابتسامته من الأذن إلى الأذن.
مهندس محمد، أتحب أن تتعلم اللغة العربية؟
والمهم أن نعمل على الفكر.
الأم في البيت، ماذا تريد أن تتعلم يا بني؟
المدرس في المدرسة،
ما هو مستقبلك عندما تكبر؟
اعملوا على الفكر لأنه مهم جدًا.
الأداة الثانية وهي الأداة العاطفية،
هل تعلم يا مهندس محمد،
لكي تصبح مهندسًا، فمن الضروري
أن تحب دراسة اللغة العربية.
غيرت تفكيره و مشاعره حيث عندما يحضر
عندي لا يكون اهتمامه تعلم اللغة،
يكون اهتمامه استخدام العلم للوصول
إلى الهدف وهي الهندسة.
فكريًا وعاطفيًا، أنا قلّصت العقد النفسية
بنسبة ثمانين بالمئة.
والأداة الثالثة، وهي أيضًا مهمة جدًا،
وهي بناء مادة تمكين وليس تمرير.
أن تكون الخطة،
لبناء اللغة عند الطفل
تناسب قدراته ومهاراته.
لا ينفع أن أدخل على ثلاثين ولد
في الحصة وأعطيهم نفس المادة.
يكون للطالب الضغيف صف خاص،
لماذا؟ يعني غريبة!
أنا أدرس من2017 وما قبل ذلك،
لا يوجد ولد أخرجته من الصف
بسبب وضعه الخاص.
لا يوجد.
لكن المعلم المحترف صاحب الرسالة،
يصمم مادة علمية تناسب القدرات
والمهارات عند الطلاب.
بهذه الثلاث أدوات،
اليوم، نحن حصلنا على أكبر الجوائز العالمية
من سلطنة عمان إلى رئاسة وزراء الأردن،
إلى الديوان الملكي في السعودية
برعاية الأميرة جوهرة.
وصلنا الى مساعدة أكثر من ألف ولد،
لحل مشاكلهم في التلعثم
وفهم المقروء وفهم المكتوب.
(تصفيق)
نصيحتي في نهاية الخطاب، أن تمنحوا أبناءكم
كتابة قصصهم في حياتهم.
ودمتم ذخرًا لأبنائكم.
(تصفيق)